♪♪
-I want to start by saying,
if you can sense a vibe...
Are you [bleep] kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
Wally and Scollins
come in chatting it up.
During "Corrections."
Is nothing sacred
in this place?
Was that one of
the guild requests?
"I wanna be able to talk
during 'Corrections.'"
[ Laughter ]
Well.
I apologize
that you had to see that.
But if you don't shame them
in the moment,
they don't learn their lesson.
I was gonna open
by explaining...
[ Laughter ]
..."Corrections" is gonna be
a little looser.
[ Laughter ]
And I realize I betrayed that
right off the bat.
But one of the reasons
"Corrections" is gonna have
a different vibe now
is that it is no longer
Emmy-nominated.
For two years,
it was Emmy-nominated.
And then during the strike,
it was un-nominated,
I think is the term they use.
If you don't get nominated, you
just don't find out anything.
If you were nominated
and then you're not,
they call you
and they request
that you stop
describing the work
as Emmy-nominated.
But, you know,
the thing about that is
I...
I feel as though
a burden has been lifted,
because I will admit
that it went to my head
and I did start chasing
the Emmy gold.
I didn't start
doing the corrections
I thought were important to do.
I started doing the corrections
that I thought the voters
would want me to do.
[ Laughter ]
And now I can just go back
to the integrity of the work,
which is what
this has always been.
Because I think,
when done right,
this is unlike anything
you watch on...
I don't know, your phone?
[ Laughter ]
Propped against the toaster
while you're drinking coffee.
So, with that relief that
this is no longer a show
that is Emmy-nominated,
came enthusiasm as I jumped
into the comments
of our viewers today.
And the first comment
I read said,
"I was surprised
he hasn't been doing these.
I thought he could do
'Corrections' during the strike
because the only thing
the writers provide
is forced laughter."
[ Laughter ]
I don't need writers
to provide forced laughter.
I got Buck.
[ Laughter ]
And that's not forced laughter.
Now, don't get me wrong.
I'm sure when he was a kid,
somebody forced him to laugh...
...and now he can't stop.
I mean, I think
we're dealing with
some sort of deep-seated trauma
that every one of these works.
"Bucky, come over to your mama.
I'm funny, aren't I, Bucky?"
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, Bucky, I don't know
what I'd do
if my baby didn't think
I was funny.
Bucky."
[ Laughter ]
Is it worth...
Here's a question we had.
When we did our first show
on Monday,
was it worth doing
"A Closer Look"
that covered
the last five months?
Is it worth...
Same question.
Is it worth doing
a "Corrections"
and going back and correcting
the last week of shows
we did five months ago
that went uncorrected.
Because people won't even
remember the errors
from five months ago.
It is worth it,
because I remember.
I have a photographic memory
of this show.
I have basically
spent five months
eating myself up inside
due to the mistakes
I made
that I had not addressed.
So I am going to start
by addressing mistakes
from five years ago
that I still remember.
Five months ago.
Excuse me.
Here's the first one.
The call with Aunt Joan
said "slide to answer."
That means the call
hadn't been answered yet.
It was still
an incoming call.
The [bleep]?
[ Laughter ]
The sun doesn't go
behind the moon.
The moon goes
in front of the sun.
The easiest way to remember
that is I don't sit
behind a standing Shoemaker
at a meeting.
I sit, and then he comes
and stands in front of me.
[ Laughter ]
Apologies, by the way,
to Shoemaker's neighbors.
Can't imagine you had
a good five months.
[ Laughter ]
Our last episode,
we made a lot of fun
about Tucker Carlson
getting fired from Fox News.
Joke's on us.
Guy landed on his feet.
Oh, another guy we made fun of
our last show, Ron DeSantis.
We did an impression of him
eating pudding
with three fingers.
And a jackal asked,
"Why are you so sure
the three figures --
the three fingers
are contiguous?"
And I think,
knowing Ron DeSantis
and how weird he is,
I'm pretty confident
it might be like...
...this.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think he's gonna
be president, guys.
[ Laughter ]
Before the break,
we were talking about
the Stevie Nicks song
"White Winged Dove."
A lot of you told me the name
of the song is "Edge of 17."
And not to give a correction
to a legend like Stevie Nicks,
but just [bleep] change it.
Don't "Baba O'Riley"
your songs.
Make it be the title
people want it to be.
You know, when you do that,
that just means some [bleep]
at a karaoke night
gets to run the computer
and people go up
and they're like,
"I would love to do
'White Winged Dove.'"
He's like, "I can't find it.
I don't think it's a song."
Someone said the sound
Stevie Nicks makes in that song
sounds more like an owl
than a dove.
And I thought,
Oh, I know what I'll do.
I'll say,
"Oh, let's take a listen,"
and I'd play a clip
from that song.
And then we'd put in,
you know,
an actual owl's hoots
over the doves.
But I can't do that.
The reason we didn't do that
is when you use a song,
due to music licensing,
it can't be on YouTube.
And I'm not complaining.
That's the rule
for everything.
You know, we put a song
in "Corrections,"
it comes off YouTube.
Same is true
of "Carpool Karaoke."
[ Laughter ]
By the way,
I don't want to...
I already regret being critical
of Stevie Nicks.
That is not someone
you want to run afoul of.
You ever listen to the lyrics
of "Silver Springs"?
Ask Lindsey Buckingham.
Because if you run afoul
of Stevie Nicks,
you wake up in the morning...
just a scarf on your pillow.
Oh, people say, "What's in your
drink, and do you finish it?"
It is a negroni,
and I do finish it.
Not during "Corrections."
I stay here the whole weekend,
in the dark,
just slowly sipping it,
and I try to finish
right before
Monday's "Closer Look."
We said Donald Trump
has been indicted three times,
which was one more
than the Unabomber.
And then I said,
"Who, as the Una implies,
just had the one."
I put that in.
Really liked it.
Nary a laugh from the audience.
And then a bunch of you
said the Una in Unabomber
was for his bombing targets.
The U-N was for universities,
the A was for airlines.
A Uni-bomber would be someone
who bombs only once.
Like me when I told
the Unabomber joke.
[ Laughter ]
And thanks to our eagle-eyed
viewer who sent in all that
Unabomber information,
Conner O'Malley.
[ Laughter ]
We said Trump looked like
a Klingon general in court
and then showed a picture
of Worf
from "Star Trek:
The Next Generation."
He was a lieutenant,
I was told by a bunch of people.
That was a bad choice
for a Klingon general.
General Martok
would have worked.
I don't like the expression
"you people,"
because it usually implies
the speaker has
some pretty bad prejudices.
With that said,
I'd just like to say
to the Star Trek fans
out there --
you people.
[ Laughter ]
We also said you could
never be a general
because the Starfleet uses
the ranks of the Navy.
Because I guess in the future,
space is water.
Taco Bell has had breakfast
since 2014.
They just added
the breakfast taco.
What's going on over there?
[ Laughter ]
Got to be stoned
to work there, too?
Aaron Rodgers did not,
as I said yesterday,
tear his ACL.
He tore his Achilles.
That's the last time
I do my own research.
[ Laughter ]
I said Laphonza Butler
is the first
Black lesbian woman
in the Senate.
I was told lesbian
and woman are redundant.
And then I decided to say
that information
as flatly as possible
and move on.
I don't love giving corrections
to my colleagues,
but oftentimes they don't have
a way to give them.
We showed a clip
of Sean Hannity,
and it's about how Trump
was gonna be
the next House speaker.
And instead of former,
they said "fromer."
Which I think
is maybe how they...
Like, if Trump calls up angrily
and he's like,
"I'm not the former president,"
they're like, "Fromer."
A lot of people said that's not
where their ears would be.
[ Laughter ]
Ah.
We showed Trump Tower.
We made it look like
"The Honeymooners."
And someone said,
"Oh, my God, you should do
'Honeymooners.'"
This is like not a correction.
This is like a pitch.
Like, "You should do a bit
where Trump's like,
'To the moon, Mel.'"
But, like, you have
to remember, like,
Trump would not have any power
in that relationship.
If Trump was like Ralph Kramden,
he'd be like,
"To the moon, Mel."
She'd be like,
"I'll tell them everything,"
And he'd be like,
"Look who's back from the moon."
I forgot we had a P.O. Box,
so it was fun to come in
and see some stuff.
I've got...
I got top three.
Someone said, you know,
"Sorry you didn't get nominated
for an Emmy."
But again, don't be sorry.
It's a relief.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine how mad I'd be
if this was Emmy-nominated
and [bleep] Scollins and Wally
are just walking in...
[ Laughter ]
You guys remember,
this all started with Legos.
Somebody made a Lego me,
and they...
That's a little Emmy.
I would've put it in the hand,
but it doesn't fit in the hand,
which I feel like
might be the joke.
[ Laughter ]
And that is a Mac Tonight
with a jackal in his pocket.
And I don't know
if you can see this.
I couldn't quite understand
what they're doing here.
It says -- There's a picture
of a Pizza Hatz
that I guess goes on it,
but it's hard to read.
But it says,
"Accessories sold separately."
So they made me a present
and showed me a picture
of another thing they made,
and I guess I gotta buy it.
[ Laughter ]
But then someone took the cake.
I mean, they said...
Somebody made this and said,
"I'm willing
to give you the patent" --
I mean, they wanted
to split the money.
Sell it at the NBC Store.
And it's for the Seth fans
who are also jackal fans.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
I mean, it's the most
haunting thing I've ever seen.
And you know, now...
Now is when I weigh something,
right?
Like, I laid in
that if Stevie Nicks
is mad at you,
she leaves a scarf
on your pillow,
and I feel like
it didn't get anything.
And so, like, I've set
something up and I'm like,
now do I call it back
by revealing
that I've run a scarf
up my sleeve?
[ Laughter ]
Like, does that pay off at all?
[ Chuckles ]
I think we're a little rusty.
[ Laughter ]
Some people forgot
what time it started.
[ Laughter ]
But you know what?
[Bleep]
I hate to say it.
Missed you guys.
Missed the jackals.
Codependency.
I've made a codependency
with a bunch of [bleep] jackals.
It's great to be back.
And...
[ Laughter ]
You know, as I'm --
as I'm watching this
in the monitor...
...one thing really...
There's like one thought
I'm having.
This shouldn't be
Emmy-nominated.
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.